neue gefahr umherstreunenden schwarze
löcher ein solches loch das nicht an ort
und stelle bleibt sondern durch unsere
milchstraße jahr streuen
das ist jetzt entdeckt worden willkommen
bei pixum zeit entwickelt 100 millionen
bis zu einer milliarde schwarze löcher
soll es allein in unserer galaxie der
milchstraße gibt lediglich rund 60 davon
kennen wir
und jetzt ist wahrscheinlich 1
dazugekommen zu gesicht bekommen wir
diese welten weil sie so lange wenig gas
oder einen stern verschlingen nahezu
unsichtbar sind
und jetzt ist ein ganz besonderes
schwarzes loch in den fokus der
wissenschaftler will ein schwarzes loch
das durch die 100 tausend lichtjahre
breite und einige hundert lichtjahre
dicke milchstraße schreibt sich also
nicht stationär an einem ort befindet
als forscher der universität die in
einer entfernung von 10 tausend lichtern
liegende supernova wie viel wirklich mit
dem achter und dem nobel yama teleskop
durchleuchteten fanden sie eine 2
lichtjahre groß wie sehr schnell mit
einer 20 kilometern pro sekunde
fortbewegen de wolke das seltsame dabei
die wolke können nicht von der
nahegelegenen sternenexplosion stammt
die tat die kinetische energie dieser
wolke ist dutzende male größer als von
der supernova b44 ausgegangen sein kann
es scheint nahezu unmöglich eine so
energiereiche wolke unter normalen
kosmischen bedingungen zu erzeugen so
mal so yamada von der keio universität
aus japan
deshalb ist eine ursache die
wahrscheinlichste ein schwarzes loch
könnte die gaswolke hinter sich
herziehen das würde also bedeuten dass
ein schwarzes loch in einer wahnsinnig
hohen geschwindigkeit in kilometern pro
stunde sind da 432.000 durch die
gaswolken der supernova durch geschossen
ist und dabei partikel aufgesaugt und
hinter sich herzieht verrückt vor allem
wenn man bedenkt dass dieses schwarze
loch mit sicherheit nicht das einzige
seiner art ist was wenn er solche
schwarzes loch in die nähe unseres
sonnensystems geraten würde wenn die
gefahr würde für unsere erde bestehen
und wie hoch ist
überhaupt die wahrscheinlichkeit dafür
wer mehr über die viel größeren
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher
wissen will der sollte unbedingt hier
draufklicken ein sehr spannendes video
und wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat
dann lass gerne ein abo da dafür einfach
hier klicken und nicht vergessen auf die
glocke zu klicken und was glaubt ihr was
wir alles noch über schwarze löcher
herausfinden wenn es gibt ja die
hypothese dass sich in jedem schwarzen
loch ein universum befindet quasi
millionen universum im universum ich bin
auf eure meinung gespannt und ansonsten
mit dann bleibt dran